j'adore le travail d'équipé mais des
fois qu'on travaille en équipe c'est off
quand ça devient difficile
quand ça devient vraiment off des fois
j'ai envie de me disent choqués tant pis
pour l'équipe là j'ai envie de penser à
moi à ma pomme un abus de dire ce que
j'ai envie de dire de face que j'ai
envie de faire
puis tant pis pour les autres
mais à chaque fois que j'ai pensé sophie
j'ai eu cette impression là
puis j'ai cherché à faire linverse de
chercher à connecter avec les gens à
bâtir des relations ça toujours été mes
plus grands succès chaque fois sans
exception juste par curiosité des gens
dans la salle qui ont déjà vécu des
situations problématiques ou des
difficultés avec des collègues au
travail the same élevé
pas mal tout le monde juste les gens qui
viennent de lever la main est-ce qu'il y
en a parmi vous qui ont déjà vu ça comme
une opportunité de se rapprocher leurs
collègues assez drôle bien le petit peu
moins
je m'y attendais mais la réalité c'est
que l'adversité on pourra jamais s'en
sauver que ce soit dans leur vie
professionnelle dans leur vie
personnelle lire toujours des variables
inconnues les trafics et les changements
des variables des surprises
qu'est ce qu'on fait avec ça si c'est si
difficile d'avancer dans des moments
d'adversité avec les autres qu'est ce
qu'on fait avec ça dans les dernières
années j'ai eu l'occasion de vivre
quelques aventures face à l'adversité
mais en équipe surtout en 2009
un déploiement en afghanistan avec les
forces armées canadiennes en 2014 j'ai
pris part à une expédition en
antarctique pour aller découvrir un
territoire où il avait jamais eu
personne qui est elle en 2015 tout
récemment j'ai eu l'occasion de pouvoir
traverser l'océan atlantique à la voile
avec des membres d'équipage dans les
dents année plusieurs fois de courir
montréal à new york à cause relais
des gens qui trois mois plus tôt avait
jamais couru ce qui m'a même dans la vie
c'est la capacité des équipes à rester
unis face à l'adversité
parce que j'ai la conviction que plus
c'est dur plus on ne la capacité
d'exprimer vraiment l'adn compte la
qualité de l'équipe qu'on est est ce que
je fais au quotidien avec mon équipe de
travers ce qu on a même des entreprises
à exploiter leur potentiel et à
optimiser leur potentiel de
collaboration puis une des méthodes
une des méthodes qu'on a dans la
méthodologie c'est de les amener à vivre
des défis on les invite à s'engager dans
un défi qui est beau c'est grand mais
qui fait peur et en mettant un pied dans
l'inconnu en sortant de la zone de
confort ne veut pas on ne la portent
unités de rentrer dans notre zone de
progression nous verrons de progression
avec ça aurait l'air de quoi si jamais
on se mettant dans la peau d'une équipe
qui fonctionne efficacement face à
l'adversité
la dernière année j'ai vu des centaines
des milliers de personnes qui ont par
exemple qui ont décidé s'engager dans le
défi
au début les gens qui travaillent
ensemble au quotidien mais qui se
connaissent pas nécessairement puis
s'engageant à préciser des défis puis
éventuellement qui relève un défi après
s'être préparé puis rendu au bout qui
interagissent les uns avec les autres
comme s'ils étaient des frappes des sols
pas que ça aurait l'air de quoi
si jamais on se lancer dans cette
situation la petite histoire juin 2014
avec une trentaine d'avocats
l'objectif font part de leurs bureaux
maurian qui on veut se rendre jusqu'à
leur bureau toronto à la course en
équipe
ça veut dire que quand on commence à
courir on laisse personne derrière on
court tout le monde ensemble jusqu'au
fil d'arrivée puis ce qui se passe à ce
moment là c'est que ça fait quatre mois
que les gens ils se préparent il se
prépare évidemment accords et qui se
prépare physiquement
bon on s'entend ils ont quand même
distance à corey may se préparent aussi
humainement à vivre ensemble dans
l'adversité
parce qu'on sait pas exactement sur quoi
ils vont tomber et l'élément c'est que
chaque personne est divisée dans un
groupe de course et tout le monde doit
courir 8 x 10 km en trois jours la
plupart de ces gens là étaient pas des
coureurs à la base est là on est moi je
suis coach que je suis avec une équipe
de quatre personnes encore c'est notre
sixième disque la main on court pied de
coin là je réalise qui appâtent malgré
tout son courage sa détermination qui
commence à ralentir
il ya un accord qui se crée en nous
piper pa tête en arrière en pis il
souffre mais il fait juste des
entrailles de souplesse entre avec les
braises il ya deux dogues sont en avant
qui décroche j'avais besoin d'eux et ils
s'en vont en arrière lui met une main
dans le dos il commence à pousser sur
terre ils viennent à notre hauteur tu
pendant ce temps là ce qui est
extraordinaire c'est parce qu'ils disent
est let's go les boys à les secouristes
go vous êtes capable pousser un truc par
les flots extraordinaire l'entr'aide
s'est poursuivie jusqu'au dixième
kilomètre comme ça puis quelques parce
que ces gars là sont en train de dire
c'est la vitesse à laquelle toi tu veux
éviter à ses quelque soit votre moi je
consens foule
ce qui est important c'est jusqu'où est
ce qu'on est capable de courir ensemble
à quel point ce qu'on est capable de
créatifs pour trouver des façons de
fonctionner puis peut-être en faisant ce
et devient pas un boulet contrairement à
ce qu'on pourrait penser et devient un
héros parce que cette capacité de
demander de l'aide ça permet quoi c'est
le permet à l'ensemble de l'équipe
d'aller au bout la mission la mission
sait pas à quelle vitesse etc avant de
courir à quelle vitesse que je
quitterais est-ce que je cours plus vite
que tout le monde la mission s'est on
cause tout le monde ensemble jusqu'au
point d'arrivée dans un contexte
organisationnel à quel point est ce
qu'on arrive fréquemment à reconnaître
la force des eaux
la force de l'équipe moi ce que
j'observe c'est que c'est quand même
relativement rare qu'on accepte de
demander de l'aide
déjà qu'on ose demander live puis fois
la ja a bien tout seul à la peine tout
seul puis c'est pas tout le temps
évident de l'accepter mais quelle
opportunité cela nous ouvrirait son
contexte comme celui là où on cherche
vraiment à être aussi fort que la force
de l'équipe
ce niveau
on change de continent juillet 2009 j'ai
24 ans en campagne à kandahar en
afghanistan avec une quarantaine de
soldats puis on est en file indienne pi
l'objectif c'est de se rendre au village
voisin pour aller le sécuriser puis
allez vivre pendant 2 3 mois pour aller
s'installer pour la fin de mission puis
je vais acheter moins cher à la fin de
la file
on est dans une espèce de couloir puis
va évidemment on regarde partout pour
être sûr qu'ils ne marchent pas sur des
murs ou quoi que ce soit et puis à un
moment donné avec la lumière mme aveugle
avant même que j'en entends leçon de
l'explosion ja sans le sou jusque dans
mes tripes mais ce qui se passe à ce
moment là c'est que je me sens
complètement impuissant 1-1 digue en
avant qui a pu laisser doubler fixons
grave les gars sont pris en charge
l'hélicoptère arrive éventuellement une
heure et demie plus tard c'est à dire
une heure et demie plus tard
l'hélicoptère arrive les gars sont
évacués pays vont être correct sauf que
nous on est tous un petit peu sur le
choc l'a évidemment ont réussi à
continuer pour terminer la mission mais
les jours suivants je réalise que j'ai
pas le même niveau d'énergie
j'ai pas le même type de focus j'ai pas
les mêmes en interaction avec les gens
je me suis plus impatients puis-je une
enquête sur - qu'est-ce qui se passe en
caisse qui se passe je réalise que il ya
des éléments sur lesquels je porte
attention qui sont pas différents qui me
tire vers le haut visuellement sur
lesquels je porte attention comme est ce
que je veux plus sur une même si jamais
je pars une jambe
comment est-ce que comment est ce que je
vais être capable de vivre ensemble
indiqué ce qui va se passer quoi
l'impact par rapport aux pis je réalise
que je puis je suis pas capable d'être
le co-équipier de michail si jamais je
ne suis pas faire équipe avec moi même
eu de vraiment prendre la responsabilité
de la façon dont je me sens des choses
que je me dis sur l'impact que cela a
sur comment je me sens la capa ce moment
je prends des décisions il faut
absolument que tout ce que je me dis à
partir de maintenant c'est là un impact
positif sur comment je me sens
ça me donne l'énergie que la capacité
même si on sait ce qui se passe à partir
de ce moment là c'est que je commence à
observer la voûte étoilée
j'apprécie les interactions que j'ai
avec des gens
les blagues mais bon on va pas qu'on a
pu chacun de ces éléments laissent ça me
donne un petit peu plus d'énergie
c'est fou parce que c'est relativement
rapide à passer devant au changement
focus mental de place et que je commence
à regarder les éléments qui me tire vers
le haut les mêmes transformations qui
s'opèrent genre comment savoir l'énergie
à voir plus de patients savoir plus de
capacité d'être en interaction avec les
gens pis est-ce que ça se peut des fois
que dans le monde du travail
quand une bombe qui saute en attendant
sa focus sur le bobo tout puis à quel
point est ce qu'on réalise l'impact de
ce qu'on pense sur l'énergie que ça
procure puis l'impact de comment on a de
l'énergie sur les autres parce que
quelque part chaque chose qu'on dit
qu'on est dans une situation des fiches
aux confins ou qu'on fait peu d'erreurs
mais simple comme une espèce de vote
pour l'équipe c'est soit ça tire
l'équipe vers le haut ou peur est-ce
qu'on est toujours en train de chercher
à tirer l'équipe vers le haut on change
encore deux continents c'est un voyage à
travers le monde 2014 février j'ai 27
ans et en antarctique avec six
aventuriers québécois le top sexy c'est
d'aller explorer un territoire inconnu y
ait jamais eu personne qui a mis les
pieds là bas il vante il fait froid et
de la neige la visibilité est pas super
bonne et on a décidé d'utiliser les deux
équipes en équipe de trois personnes
dans mon équipe
hier françois magna puis un mois qui
nous séparent on est tous rattachés par
là même quand on descend est-ce qu'une
montagne françois prend un virage du
françois indice perd aussitôt je vois la
corde qui seront françois marne puis moi
ben on se ramasse par terre qu'on est
emporté vers le trou la vitesse accélère
je monterai dans ma main je l'enfance
dans neige puis choque le plus ce calcul
le taux maximum de mes capacités
puis j'ai vraiment la certitude que la
chute avait jamais arrêté puis
tranquillement ça ralentit puis s'arrête
à ce moment là j'ai mal partout le poids
sur mes hanches aux mondiaux il est
terrible j'ai la certitude que ça va
décrocher à n'importe quel moment depuis
que j'ai pas la force physique qu'il
faut pour être capable de m'en sortir je
me dis hein j'ai besoin dun entraîne
donc je me lève la tête je me retourne
d'abord je vois mme harriman marne est
une super fait de montagnes
une guide de montagne mais marine est
dans un état à la joue qui reviendrait
comme ça à l'envers puis alain boudou
qui me dit ici elle a passé une audition
pour le cirque du soleil ce moment là
c'est ce qu'elle leur est alors la face
d'un match puis je me dis comment on
fait pour respirer mais j'ai besoin d'un
oeil parce que je sais que je serai pas
capable de tenir enfin j'ai vu mes
rivaux
bas rhinois est ce que tu peux m'aider
avec le poids et panjas chine mais comme
ça mais je m'excuse
ok
avec la certitude que je peux garder
notre naissance pour l'invoquer c'est
fini tu as été jeu presque confortable
avec lui parce que je le sais me
convainquent export photo dans votre
conservateur puis je réussis à me
convaincre
j'ai une bonne vie chez elle au bout de
mes rêves j'ai plein de souvenirs c'est
correct
ce sera un bon moment je tenterai de
visualiser ma mort mais je réalise en
fait j'ai une vision qui m'apparaît plus
la vision c'est la suivante
j'arrête de penser à moi champ de mon
corps je pense à marine appuyé à
françois blais j'imagine françois tic
lui est dans le trou et la corde qui
peint j'ai comme la misère à accepter ou
à voir que françois lui et comme point
pour être une belle journée pour mort et
se 66 80 67 ans beau mot shit à l'aise
si cet impôt je me ramasse en campagne
plus bon un champ très vaste 300 mètres
plus bas dans ma j'arrive paul je
résiste à cette image la plus creuse
venant qu'est ce qui fait que je résiste
au temps puis j'ai réalisé en fait que
quand il était à montréal
quatre mois plus tôt en train de se
préparer pour physiquement que
techniquement mais mentalement en train
de s'engager qu'est ce qui se passe pour
nous le pour que notre défi soit un
succès on était tous en train de dire il
faut qu'on fasse tout en notre possible
pour que tout le monde revienne à maison
pis en acceptant maman je sois en train
de respecter mon engagement
mais à partir de ce moment-là je me dis
il faut que je fasse tout en mon
possible pour respecter mon engagement
un engagement c'est fort
à partir du moment où je pense pouf il
ya de l'énergie l'un à fond qui me vient
j'occupe des comment je me suis pris
mais une heure plus tard j'avais réussi
à installer un système dans neige qui
permettait de libérer mes mains du
marina elle avait été capable de
décrocher de la corde de venir m'aider
puis à 2 en équipe on était capable de
bâtir quelque chose qui allait permettre
à françois sortie de la leçon la plus
importante pour moi de ce n'est que
d'autres le sais que c'est pas la
préparer
physique ce n'est pas la préparation
technique c'est vraiment notre capacité
à connecter les uns avec les autres
la clarté notre engagement qui a fait
toute la différence il ya quel point
aujourd'hui qu'on travaille qu'on tombe
dans une crevasse où on a quelqu'un un
collègue dans une crevasse
on est plein air avec ckoi leur
engagement à des kits qui va nous
permettre nous en sortir par
l'engagement il ya une étude qui a été
fait par galope sur l'engagement au
travail à travers le monde un million de
personnes 26 payé puisqu'ils se sont
rendu compte en fait c'est qu'ils ont
pris le pourcentage ayant ramené ça les
données qui ont ramené ça une équipe de
foot de sang que onze personnes se sont
rendues compte que sur les 11 personnes
de l'équipe de soccer c'est comme s'il y
avait seulement quatre personnes qui
savaient exactement dans quel but
doivent marquer c'est comme s'il y avait
deux personnes qui savaient exactement
c'est quoi le poste qu'ils doivent jouer
deux personnes imaginez ce que ça veut
dire que dans une organisation il reste
neuf personnes qui vont travailler
travail mais qui sont pas 100 % sur
qu'est ce qu'ils sont en train de faire
ça sans l'organisation
neuf ans plus de cigarettes deux
personnes qui chercheraient à jouer
contre leur propre équipe qui a marqué
dans leur but mais c'est quoi ça c'est
de la démobilisation c'était des
engagements selon la harvard business
review un employé qui est pas engagé
veut veut pas c'est sûr que vos - être
portée à faire preuve d' efforts du
questionnaire pour supporter les
objectifs organisationnels
bon c'est clair vaut moins de porter à
se donner puis être productif qu'en plus
de ça il va sûrement avoir une influence
négative sur les employés qui sont le
langage et le rap statistiques et toutes
françaises qui étaient faites beaucoup
plus petit avec 1000 cadres en france
par opinionway zh
et puis ce qui ont cherché à voir
finalement c'est quoi les sources de
stress principal au travail il ya 41 %
des gens qui ont nommé les relations
avec la hiérarchie comme étant une
source principale de stress 41% avant la
peur de perdre son emploi
est-ce que ça se pourrait être lancé
comme ça je serais curieux en saurons
plus est-ce que ça se pourrait qu'un
lien entre le peu d'engagement plus de
clarté qu'on a sur la vision
l'entreprise puis le rôle qu'on doit
jouer puis les relations médias qu'on a
avec les gens qui sont supposés créer
cette vision de passer là qu'en
terminant si vous me demandez c'est quoi
pour moi mon équipe de rêve mon équipe
du futur l'équipe que je vois c'est une
équipe définitivement qui est efficace
pour faire face à l'adversité
ça veut dire que c'est des gens qui ont
la capacité de 1 d'avoir une vision qui
est claire non seulement la vision est
claire mais l'ensemble des membres de
l'équipe ils sont engagés
puis savent qu'ils sont en train d'y
contribuer dans tout ce qu'ils disent
dans tout ce qu'ils font le deuxième
élément c'est que on a une équipe ici
qui est capable de reconnaître la force
du nombre qui cherchent à passer la
mission collective avant les gros pulls
succès individuel on l'espère les bonis
ou on les définit je sais pas est-ce
qu'on peut créer des systèmes pour nous
permettre de gagner tout le monde
ensemble ou de perdre tout le monde
ensemble ils troisième élément c'est que
l'enfant des membres dans cette équipe
du futur leur qui fait face à
l'adversité à la capacité de reconnaître
qu est ce qui fait que j'ai de l'énergie
c'est quoi l'impact de ce que je suis
dit sur comment je me sens puis sur
commande interagit avec les autres puis
à tout moment je cherche à avoir un
impact qui tire l'équipe vers le haut
si jamais vous êtes curieux de voir un
petit peu à quoi ça pourrait ressembler
si jamais vous viviez l'adversité façon
efficace avec des collègues soit
déraisonnable
allez je sais pas sortis du bureau
allait marcher sous la pluie fait
quelque chose d'un petit peu
extraordinaire puis observer c'est quoi
les réactions c'est quoi les
comportements que tout est correct mais
cherchait peut-être en parler après puis
à voir comment est-ce qu'on peut
s'améliorer par rapport s en terminant
puis je voulais c'est là dessus il ya
les équipes actuellement qui vous équipe
corporative des entreprises qui
traversent des océans qui monte de
montagne qui cherchent à traverser des
pays parce qu'ils veulent redéfinir
c'est quoi le travail d'équipé
je vous lance la question avoue pas quel
type d'équipé vous envie de contribuer
merci